our friends over at the good liars  davrum and jason really trolled the  nra's wayne lapierre so beautifully  where they went up pretending to defend  him saying hey all these people blamed  wayne lapierre for shootings but wayne  lapierre did a lot after and they list  all these shootings he sent thoughts and  prayers and there should be more  thoughts and prayers sent and of course  they're trolling him it's  tongue-in-cheek the nra under wayne  lapierre's leadership  has provided  thoughts  and prayers  to the victims and their families but at  a certain point  we have to say the prayer is not working  pray if you want but if the prayer  really worked couldn't you use it to  prevent the shootings instead of only  praying after the fact come on guys